bourbon est un exemple de modernité
tu as un iphone ou un iphone un iphone
tu fais des photos vers le haut un
iphone ne tuaient des photos horizontale
à l'accord s'il y avait une coupe
d'europe des villes les mieux équipées
on sera au shopping slick jasmin
haïtiano neige mais il n'est jamais un
port vendres mais monsieur le maire la
situation est catastrophique trop
d'équipés trop de personnel trop de
véhicules dans ce monde il atteint pour
les poids lourds et
du lundi 7 mai 2009 mais je prends deux
jours de rtt que ce qui fait que quand
j'arrive au lundi de la compote et je
reprends le travail mardi j'ai pris deux
jours et j'en ai eu 11 22 millions
d'euros de déficit ménard comme une
solution là je vous préviens je vous
couper les vivres aux réductions
budgétaires
c'est cuit à new york le mec qui a fait
l'ena qui est une uc sûr mais là il faut
pas lâcher
ils vont craquer apprécié de paris
centre centre je veux de la finesse je
veux du surge ical j'espère les six deux
corées plaisir c'est lipkin 13 c'est
parti
qui est pour que ça retombe sur le
service des eaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bernard le nouveau à ces dates ouais là
j'ai appris à déposer les rtt
essentielle pour tenir t il sera de
pagodes la pression collard me tant que
tu y es pas que tu peux pas te rendre
compte
[Musique]